hola qué tal muy buen día unas cifras
que se dieron a conocer pasadas las 11
de la noche hora local prácticamente
tres horas más de tres horas después de
que se había cerrado el proceso
electoral con más del 97 por ciento de
las actas escrutadas sergio garrido se
alzó con el 55 punto 36 por ciento esto
corresponde a más de 172 mil votos y
jorge realza el candidato del chavismo
con 41 puntos 27 por ciento
correspondiente a 128 mil 583 votos
llama la atención que la brecha es mucho
mayor a los resultados de las elecciones
del pasado 21 de noviembre en los que
también ganó la oposición con presión
por la no al frente pero con una
diferencia de 130 votos apenas menos de
uno por ciento porcentual estos
resultados y aquí la brecha fue de 14
puntos porcentuales una derrota como lo
decías para el chavismo que gobernó ese
estado durante 22 años es sergio garrido
el primer opositor en lograr este
triunfo desde